[Music]
okay so this is my review of your honor
episode five this is directed by
clark johnson and written by dwayne
darion jones
so we're coming right away from where we
left off with this
crazy cliffhanger of the jones household
being blown up
you see now the only boy left in the
family eugene you feel for him he's got
the shirt on with his mom and his
siblings are at this funeral reception
going on
in this side of town and we get
introduced to a big new character
literally in big mo now i really like
big mo is introduced here
it's at the perfect time to kind of now
have a catalyst to someone who's going
to respond to this
blow up of the jones house to the
baxters it puts another big kind of
leader character besides michael
the baxters and her now making this like
triangular effect of like a war going on
now an interesting change in events is
little mo his character
basically tells eugene how a cop really
need a car stolen
for kofi and big moan little moe would
reveal this to the baxters later on
so remember little moe's living with
guilt of what happened to kofi now
and also to the family because he was
the one who told kofi to plead guilty
and not to squeal but now
little moe himself is saying what really
went down
because of the threat now of the baxters
thinking that they're the result of
their son's death now what i thought was
kind of
odd about this episode it stuck out to
me was especially with little moe's
character where he felt like he was
teleporting from scene to scene because
this whole episode takes place
in one day and we go to different areas
but in particular little mo
his outfit is changing everywhere he's
going
and you're wondering how he's like
teleporting it feels like
because we first see him this day at
this funeral section
then he's working on the streets with
eugene who's also in a different shirt
in the same day and this is at lunch
time and then
he appears at the baxters at this hotel
in a completely different outfit
followed quickly by eugene showing up to
him and also another shirt and he's in a
different outfit
giving him these bed sheets there was
weird feeling of it not feeling like a
realistic day in this episode and that
also goes to
where adam's at this cafe all day not
answering the phone calls of his father
but fia shows up just happens to answer
this cafe but decide to only go to her
family's hotel gathering
and pops up to say hi to carlo and then
goes to this cafe and
you're just like how is everyone getting
everywhere so quickly
and conveniently it did feel like there
were so
many locations and not enough
establishing shots either to kind of
catch your breath as the audience and
kind of realize
where are we in this day and i mean you
even have our lead michael start out in
court
then go home to deal with this threat
bring the dog to the animal hospital
then goes back
to court to work and then goes back to
the animal hospital
and then back home to adam while this
whole time adam was just preparing for
this insanely i guess long interview but
there's some
really intense suspense going on here
especially in the open where
getting blackmailed now i love he's
gotta go home
he sees there's the newspaper article
someone's telling him he knows adam did
it
he's got the bat and it really gets you
on the edge of your seat right away
there is some odd pacing issues with the
show though because the show will open
with that kind of pace
and then in particular this episode it
will just completely slow down in like a
scene with the cafe with adam and fia
there's not really a
great rhythm of this episode where it
has some really fast-paced scenes and
some really slow scenes and
it's not really totally all in sync and
like i'm saying it's like this giant
puzzle piece of a day you're trying to
kind of stay and figure out where you
are but what really stood out to me here
was the cinematography i think it
actually
stole the show for me in this episode i
love the cinematography just on the
scene with big mo on the porch
talking to eugene and this lighting they
had of the sun on her was just
really beautiful shot and they also do a
good job of showing
what a character's feeling with the
camera in particular in the cafe scene
with adam every time
fia even mentions her brother we get a
shallow focus
in the environment of adam and he's
clearly got some anxiety when that's
brought up so they really put you in the
mood of each character
usually adam michael in a scene with the
camera there's always funny details
though
i love shows dude that i always laugh at
like one in particular was when
the blackmailer texted michael when he's
at the hospital and
he wants 222 thousand dollars i would
love to just
like text back if i was michael can we
call it 220 000 does it need to be
exactly 222
such a random number like in the writers
room when they're deciding that like
who's where's the guy standing up
raising his hand and being like you know
what why don't we just make it 220 000.
why did you say 222. but clearly the
writing's on the wall here with adam and
fia's relationship it's almost becoming
this like
romeo and juliet story where they're now
in these
really bad separate camps that they
shouldn't even be talking
but they're actually starting to like
each other romantically here there is a
connection
and you kind of just roll your eyes at
adam constantly like how is this
smart to even be talking to a baxter but
maybe
it will be something that saves their
butt in the end because she seems like
the only sane baxter in this story so
they're kind of
making that character that can we can
kind of get some sensibility from that
angle of that family also i complained
before about the casting choice of
adam's teacher and that she looks too
similar to his age
i have another complaint in that
category when we see lee meets
kofi's father he looks the same age as
kofi i
really am appalled when they do this
kind of casting where it just does not
represent in your head what you would
envision
age-wise contrasting to the character
you knew and then meeting the father it
just
put up a blank for me i know i'm
nitpicking but i do think all these
little things are subconsciously so
important to
the quality of a show feeling like
you're realistically in this
world now i really love this scene with
big mo showing up
to jimmy baxter and this is a big moment
it's gonna change everything because
she's now
explaining to him you got the wrong guy
and it was interesting too the camera
showing here that carlo felt a little
guilt there
for killing kofi that wait a second did
i do something wrong here did kofi not
kill my brother
and this is just a big twist and jimmy's
really wants to make sure he got the
right person he wants
true justice so this sets an alarm off
to him
and i love by the end of this episode he
figures it out through this gas station
that oh my god this judge deleted this
footage he gave the gas station worker a
fake name
so now he knows who's a prime suspect
here
i absolutely love stoolbark's
performance in this episode especially
when he
confronts the cop informant he uses
saying you think we're done here like
this is my effing son we're talking
about i thought that was just
brilliant delivery by him and he's
really bringing his a-game into this
role and embracing it now it's
interesting we see amy this porch
neighbor we've been hinted at a lot
watching what's been going down at
michael's house but she mentions that
there was a man there in a green toyota
camry he was a white man with a
horseshoe
logo in the window giving us the hint of
who this blackmailer can be
on the phone with the black mirror he
sounded like he had a very high-pitched
voice like a younger voice
i still obviously think this is this
mysterious character
who we saw following adam that day in
the black vehicle
and he also saw him taking pictures of
the crime scene and we'll see
that i would assume this black car took
the picture of him
or video at the gas station he sends to
michael
at the end of this episode but i love
the turn of michael's character here
when he goes to see the black male he
doesn't have the money and he says i
don't think you have the evidence
to pull this off or the balls to see
this through i have to say i know people
get annoyed every time i mention
breaking bad but come on it reminds me
of walter white that's why i love seeing
it but
it's just like something he would do i
have to acknowledge that it's there you
see it if you watch breaking bad it just
comes back to you but it ended really
strong this episode
having now jimmy baxter figure out
oh my god this judge knows who killed my
son and
this is a catalyst now to make me feel
like episode 6 is going to be
crazy and that we got this blackmailer
involved
and michael's just got all these things
happening that are a result of his
decision to cover up what happened with
adam everything is breaking everyone's
getting onto him you got lee
also catching on more and more to what
really happened to kofi so
i'm excited to see how this all plays
out this got me a lot more interested
again
it was a good setup episode for which
should be a crazy episode six calming
down a bit
from the blow up in last episode's
cliffhanger but now setting to this big
moment at the mid point of the season
that jimmy baxter
now is on to michael so in general it's
a stronger episode this season i'm
actually going to give this one an 8.5
and the only reason i don't give it a
little higher is because i still felt
like
the way it was presented timeline wise
was confusing it's not that i didn't get
where we were but it was
hard task almost too hard it they made
it over complicated and
where people were appearing and i don't
think it adds anything and helps your
cause when you're changing their outfits
each scene too like
little moe in those scenes he's moving
so fast but it feels like that where
you're like what day is it because he's
wearing these very bright outfits but
you're like
why did he change he keeps changing
every scene just keep it the same outfit
so it keeps us
just subconsciously remembering where we
are and what day and who we're following
let me know your theories down below who
this blackmailer is what you think is
going to happen next
how you're liking the show did you like
this episode in particular i love to
read every comment and i try to respond
as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of your
honor i also reviewing other shows at
the moment like cobra kai
and servant and i also do celebrity
interviews you don't want to miss that
and if you really love what i do here
i'd really appreciate a two dollar
monthly donation you can commit to
with my paypal link down below it will
give me the opportunity to do videos
full time that's my dream and get more
videos out to you guys and please follow
me at steve varley show on twitter
instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time